[Music]
yeah
the Japanese Japanese yeah but in your
country did you hear muhammad baba the
surah Avella sinto is a kind of a mean
ism yeah order the Buddhism yeah yeah
nature is bad yeah you know what Islam
says mmm that the creator created
creation so you only worship the one who
created the creation and God Almighty's
only one he sent messengers and they all
came with same message
there's only one God worshipping yes a
message just one guy so instead of
worshipping nature you worship the one
who created nature make sense hahaha so
you heard of Jesus Moses Abraham and all
the prophets they came with the same
message Islam because Islam needs to
submit your will to one God and Muhammad
being the last messenger if you want
proof you look in the Quran
try this is not coincidence you see
things happen you believe things happen
for a reason
Japanese yep from America a meeting and
go from America yes already but my
background here and now I came here to
give you a message
Oh huffing I didn't have to go to Japan
you made my job easy
we're very nice to meet you okay so we
just met a person from Japan and you
always have opportunities they come up
now you notice I was really quick and
short doesn't have to be long
but you see in there he shared with us
what he actually believed animism the
creation worship and this is what you
find in all man-made religions ways of
life you find that one way or another
people like you said he believes that
the creation is God that's another proof
that there is only one God and that
these messengers that I had mentioned
Jesus Moses Abraham Noah and Muhammad
peace and blessings be upon them all
they were the ones who brought the pure
monotheism so call people away from what
he was saying he worshiped and what a
great number of human beings have fallen
into a lot of people because of
ignorance a lot of people because of
following blindly what their ancestors
their family their tribes their culture
does but the truth is clear and stands
out and that truth is that God Almighty
the creator and Arabic Allah is only one
that you worship the Creator alone and
you don't worship what he created so you
don't worship nature you don't worship
the sun the moon the messenger saints
you don't worship Jesus you don't
worship Muhammad you don't worship
nobody or nothing but the one who
created you it's not simple to
understand so we shared that real quick
and then the person has to think these
things don't happen by chance this is
how a lot of signs that are sent subtle
signs and now a person has to think
you're in in Bosnia
I'm coming from America he's coming from
Japan and now you get hit with the
message so you also who are listening
and shell off you're grasping this also
it's very easy to digest and understand
and let's continue on subscribe if you
haven't already you can follow us here
in our trip halfway around the world
visiting this beautiful country in the
heart of Europe Bosnia
all right we're here slide the famous
bridge famous bridge of Moscow where
people are known to jump off this bridge
[Music]
there's a really powerful statement
remember that that the truth is hidden
from one or two people one is the one
who turns away from it and two is the
one who's just too proud too proud maybe
arrogant we don't want to fall in that
trap so the truth comes - you should be
humble sincere you have any doubts look
into it but at the end be sincere and
accept it